[Musik]
und im verschneiten münchen begrüße ich
den präsidenten des verbandes der
forschenden pharma-unternehmen guten tag
herr stoll guten morgen also
lieferverzögerungen bei astrazeneca
mengen reduzierungen bei kaiser und das
trotz schon geleistete
millionenzahlungen aus berlin und
brüssel haut die politik jetzt zu recht
auf den putz das sollten sie die politik
frage natürlich aber ich denke dass wir
in einer phase sind die natürlich sehr
spannend ist und sehr belastend für die
gesellschaft aber aus meiner perspektive
muss ich sagen dass es unvorstellbar ist
wie schnell die impfstoffe auf den markt
gekommen sind und wie hoch die
produktion schon gefahren worden ist und
auch im moment noch weiter erweitert
wird
aber es ist klar dass es am anfang war
jetzt noch immer sind auch
kinderkrankheiten gegeben hat aber mal
konkret brüssel hätte einen bösen
verdacht nämlich den dass astrazeneca wo
sie selbst mal gearbeitet haben abnehmer
wie großbritannien oder auch andere
länder außerhalb der eu mit ungekürzten
mengen beliefert vielleicht sogar
kontingente die für die eu bestimmt
waren abzweigt halten sie das für
möglich
ich kann das nicht beurteilen
also sie sagten schon ich habe für
astrazeneca gearbeitet aber es schon
länger her und ich weiß nicht wie die
verhandlungen jetzt auf höchster ebene
ablaufen
es ist klar dass es da quasi eine
diskussion gibt das ist ganz klar aber
ich glaube dies noch nicht zum ende
geführt und das ist das wichtigste dass
die die seiten jetzt sich intensiv
austauschen halte ich für völlig normal
wie gesagt es ist eine spannende zeit
berührt uns alle
das ist viel bedeutender dass er sehr
schnell klarheit kommt und auch eine
gute lösung für beide seiten
es ist ja schon beeindruckend gewesen
mit welcher schnelligkeit die
pharmaindustrie neue impfstoffe
entwickelt hat und das immer noch tut
aber mit der produktion scheint sie doch
zumindest teilweise überfordert
welche lehren muss ihre branche für die
zukunft daraus ziehen müssen forschung
entwicklung auf der einen seite die
produktion auf der anderen seite
vielleicht doch mehr hand in hand gehen
ich glaube das ist genau was was
passiert und ich möchte es gerne
klarstellen
denn wo jetzt gesagt wird wir haben zu
wenig impfstoff kann ich das
nachvollziehen aber die erweiterung der
produktion findet schon seit monaten
statt aus so piontek deutsches
unternehmen aus erstes auf den markt
gekommen mit ihrem impfstoff hat schon
im september
da war noch nicht klar wie die
ergebnisse aussehen würden
und auch noch keine zulassung da war
haben sich schon im september haben die
eine produktionsanlage gekauft die auch
direkt zur verfügung stehen könnte um zu
produzieren und dann dauert es noch
immer sechs monaten bevor es so weit ist
denn die firma aufgegeben dass die in im
februar hoffen produzieren zu können in
dieser anlage in marburg und das
bedeutet dass die vorrichtung gesagt
haben wir haben eine produktion von 1 3
milliarden 1,3 milliarden dosen in 2021
bei einer firma die seit 2008 besteht
und noch nie ein produkt auf den markt
gebracht hat und haben dann vor kurzem
auch gesagt wegen der erweiterung in
marburg dass die in diesem jahr zwei
milliarden 1000 produzieren werden aber
natürlich im gesamten jahr ist das eine
unglaubliche leistung und zeigt gerade
dass die pharmaindustrie sehr gut im
stande ist von null auf hundert zu gehen
gestern gab es einmal eine gute
nachricht er hat nämlich sanofi
angekündigt pfizer und bayon tag eben
bei der produktion ihres corona
impfstoffs zu helfen
bis ende des jahres sollen mehr als 100
millionen dosen dieses vakzins eben von
sanofi für die europäische union
hergestellt werden
als laie fragt man sich ein bisschen
warum nicht gleich so also das ist
relativ einfach zu beantworten sanofi
ist einer der grössten impfstoff
hersteller der welt haben sehr
geforscht um auch mit einem eigenen
impfstoff zu kommen
dann hat die effektivität nachgelassen
das hat alles mit studien auflagen zu
tun und so weiter und haben jetzt
kapazität frei um da extra zu helfen
also sie sehen wie stark sich forschende
industrie hier auch zusammenarbeitet
aber es war auch klar und das ist
wahrscheinlich der beste beweis für
jetzt dass wir wieder ein bisschen ruhe
kriegen also der größte
impfstoffhersteller kann aushelfen
denn die haben schon die
produktionsanlagen zur verfügung aber
nichtsdestotrotz offen die im august
also noch mal wieder sechs monate später
im august die erste lieferung die ersten
sendungen zu liefern zu können
das deutete selbst wenn der überwiegende
teil der bevölkerung irgendwann geimpft
sein wird werden ja menschen weiter an
group it 19 erkranken um so wichtiger
sind arzneimittel gegen die krankheit an
denen geforscht wird die bundesregierung
hat gerade 200.000 dosen von zwei
antikörper mitteln gekauft die in der eu
bisher aber nicht zugelassen sind ist es
richtig diese mittel jetzt an profit
patienten quasi auszuprobieren zu testen
wenn wir das ausmaß der pandemie und der
krankheit jetzt wie das auch die die die
normale gesellschaft unglaublich
beeinflusst hatte ich das für sehr
richtig denn die studiendaten sind da es
gibt schon eine note zulassung in den
usa es gibt schon relativ viel erfahrung
und wenn das von ärzten hier in
deutschland eingesetzt wird
die sich ganz gut auskennen mit dieser
krankheit und auch mit dem verlauf
dieser krankheit da hatte ich das für
absolut richtig
neue medikamente entwickeln mich nur
gegen korona ist ja ein ziemlich
aufwendiger auch teurer prozess braucht
normalerweise 12 jahre oder mehr
bis so ein arzneimittel auf den markt
kommt wird diese pandemie genau wie die
impfstoff auch die
medikamentenentwicklung langfristig
verändern beziehungsweise beschleunigen
ich hoffe es aber ich denke dass sie
hier wirklich ein extremfall
bei den impfstoffen wo wir jetzt von 2
auf den markt auf dem markt haben und
hoffentlich am freitag kommt dann auch
wieder
der impfstoff von apotheker dazu und
hoffentlich mit einigen wochen im ersten
quartal noch auch noch einen impfstoff
auch noch ein softphone von johnson
johnson johnson
das ist unglaublich nah gegangen und
sehr erfolgreich wir sollten aber nicht
vergessen dass wir ungefähr 260 projekte
weltweit haben mit forschung und
entwicklung von impfstoffen also in der
breite ist das etwas was wir noch nie
gesehen haben und wir dürfen auch nicht
annehmen dass das normal wird denn die
breite der forschung ist gerade
natürlich etwas was wir aus menschen
brauchen es gibt noch sehr viele
krankheiten die jetzt schlecht oder noch
nicht geheilt werden kann
einblicke des präsidenten des verbandes
der forschenden pharma-unternehmen hand
schütteln ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch und größe nach münchen